hello folks
welcome to rational science
today we seem to have uh goddess
as part of the audience okay that's good
i gotta better behave today then
anyways uh we're gonna be dealing with
dark energy today a little later on but
let's start with the situation in the
world
and we have a situation there in ukraine
uh the russians have um incorporated
two of their the provinces of ukraine
into the russian empire okay so let's
all pull out the champagne bottles and
celebrate
okay
and uh like i said in the past i'm
saying this war
has nothing to do with ukraine okay this
war is against germany
germany lost the first world war lost
the second world war germany is going to
lose this war as well this this is a
loss for germany and here you have uh
schultz he's the
uh
chancellor of germany and it was like
the prime minister the president right
and
he says that germany has took taken
steps to halt
the certification of nordstrom 2 which
is a gas pipeline that
comes from russia all the way to germany
and
it was about to be certified
but now they're going to postpone it
and
it's important to know that the head of
that project is a fellow known as
schrodinger who was
pres chancellor of germany in the past
and good friend of schultz and so i'm
sure they're not very happy with the
fact that the united states is imposing
this on them it's like a
you know lose-lose situation for germany
and you can see there it says pressure
from the united states
uh and uh pipeline bringing natural gas
from germany from russia to germany
increases europe's reliance on russian
energy supplies
that's what uh
the united states fears that germany
might fall too too much or too far
into the russian sphere it's already
fallen into the chinese sphere because
china is the cun it's its number one
partner as far as business is concerned
and so you can see that the united
states is a little worried about that
and you know there are situations uh
where um
for example the united states wants to
punish
either russia or china
and i'll just give an example let's say
the united states says to china we're
not going to sell any more cars to you
and then germany steps in and says oh we
can sell you some cars we'll send you
some mercedes-benz or
whatever and so that's what the united
states wants to stop uh the united
states wants germany on board
uh with the other 50 stars okay
and not only germany but france
essentially france and germany i think
those are
going to be the big losers this time
around
and yeah because uh in the case of
russia it's already made some pacts with
china so i think
russia has some what a solution to its
problems its economic problems not
completely this is going to hurt them
but they have at least
resolved some of the issues before they
went into the ukraine
but france and germany i don't know
they're going to have to switch their
economics adjusted so that they
fall more in line with the united states
empire and so it's going to be
interesting what's going to happen next
few years if we make it that far and all
i can say is you know on the other hand
you got to look at the united states
and i've said it before i'm going to say
it again
um
the worst thing that can happen to the
world right now
is for the us economy for the american
economy to collapse
you know uh if the united states uh
economy collapses
we are all dead
okay and so right now we got to do
everything possible in our power to prop
up the u.s economy i don't care what
your political leanings are
that's what we got to do okay that's all
i'm saying
okay and here you see uh
a version of that uh not mine this is
from the new york times um
leonhard he writes the phone he says
political freedom has declined every
year since 2006.
democracies are in decline and that's
all over the world okay
uh and that says that u.s and europe are
struggling to lift living standards
okay so th this is an important point
there and i guess one of the reasons for
that is primarily europe is already
completely developed
you know there's not much more you can
develop here in europe uh
in the next few years
yeah you can expand some services you
can maybe expand a little bit your
manufacturing but
you know
it's all done
it's like if you want to put a new
business what are you going to put a car
company and compete against the big
corporations that exist around the
planet already distributing cars it's
gonna be very tough for you to beat
those big companies aside from the fact
that they might buy you off from the
start and and just neutralize you if you
have some good product
and there it says major political
parties behaving in
anti-democratic ways and uh this
apparently has a beef against the
republican party
uh he put that as an example
but his last statement there that's the
one that's really gets true to you it
says the american-led order is in deep
crisis
okay now of course you may not agree
with what this fellow is saying
uh
but all i'm all i can tell you is you
don't want the us economy to fall apart
and one of the problems you've got there
is that empires do need to expand
you know um if they don't expand like
you know the roman empire once it
reached the borders of the
you know barbarians
uh
they got stopped
and
what was interesting they hired a lot of
these german you know barbarian generals
and some of them
eventually ended up attacking rome
so
you figure out how this is going to play
out
and that's in one side
there's another issue that was popular
these last few
these last couple weeks in fact
and it's this uh lady her name is ghoul
she's a skier for the for uh china but
she was born in the united states
raised and educated in the united states
but she competed for china
and
nikki haley who was a
ambassador to the un
she was really upset at that and like
many other people as well
and they're saying that she weighed in
on american-born skier
beijing game star eileen gu haley said
guru needs to pick a side between the us
and china every athlete needs to know
when they put their flag on you're
standing for freedom or you're standing
for human rights abuses
so she didn't like the fact that goo
who's from california speaks perfect
english
went there and uh
and got medals
for the other side
how can you do this okay
and all i can give you is my take on
this and that's that you know all these
uh sports games
uh they should remove
nations
from it completely
you know we got this from the
city-states in greece
uh where each city state was a country
you know as uh all the pals all the
buddies in our hometown
and that was the nation the city-state
and so when they got together you know
everybody fought for the city-state
but that was you know two thousand over
two thousand years ago
today
you know you would think that we've
evolved from that
it turns out we still have nations today
and people fight for the nation
now that's okay in a military way you
know you want to fight for your country
go ahead and you know fight for your
country
but in sports should we have nations in
sports
you know when argentina and brazil play
soccer it's a big deal
and they start the game
by playing the national anthems and they
do this all over the world when two
nations play
and the question is
you know are these
22 players
on you know on the field are they
doing it for the country or should they
be doing it for sports for the hell of
uh playing of you know having fun and
you know having a good time
and the same for the olympics you know
and in the case of
the super bowl or you know world series
they only play
one national anthem i never understood
why
[Laughter]
but the the issue is you know
should we have nationality into sports
and i think that's where the problem
begins you know if if we didn't have
nationality into
sports there wouldn't be any sabotage or
anything like that you know people would
just go to china or to russia or to
united states and just have a good time
and everybody just watches the best
athletes on the planet it would be great
if we could get nationality out of the
whole picture no flags you know just an
individual medal if you want to have a
metal
contest for metal or for prizes or
whatever that's fine
but it's when you put the flag
into
sports i think that's when trouble
starts
so i think all flags should be removed
from sports
and
people should just have a good time and
you know play for the fun of it and and
and then if we're not worried about the
country then maybe we get that off our
backs and we can play better in the
field you know but if people are
thinking oh what is my country going to
think of me
and it turns out you know you you
listen to your anthem you put your
hand in the heart and then when your
team loses they go and lynch you
your own your own countrymen go lynch
okay so i don't know
anyways let's move on to another issue
and it's this um
we have the moonies and the loonies and
the flat earthers okay what are the flat
earthers well people who say that we've
never went
to space because if we happen to go into
space we could have very easily taking
up taking a picture or filmed you know
the uh
the earth
from afar and we would know if it's
round if it's flat we would know if it's
spinning we would know a lot of stuff
right just by looking at the movie and
a human doesn't go have to go up there
we could do it with you know just a
satellite or whatever
and then we have the moonies uh the
moonies say we never went to the moon
okay
so and you have all kinds of ranges
there some people say we haven't even
gone into space others say we haven't
even gone to the moon
and
obviously if that's the case we'll never
go to mars because some people believe
we cannot
a human cannot
escape the earth and live partly because
of
radiation partly because of uh vacuum
and then you have the loonies and we're
gonna deal with those today again one
more time
for those of you who have something
better to do well don't do it just stick
around and you might learn something and
so you have these loonies and they
believe that the moon spins
and no we're going to argue that the
moon does not spin okay
okay so uh let's start with this fellow
we're going to start with some of the
common questions people made and they're
all related to
these loonies
that believe that the moon spins okay
here's the first one it says the moon
spins
and said nothing else
okay
you'd be nice if you
say a little more than then you know
justify that the moon spins that's a lot
harder
and so to say and make a statement that
the moon spins you said nothing okay
nothing that concerns science at least
okay another fellow says
the moon has an axis that rotates with
it
uh
so the moon doesn't spin earth's axis
doesn't rotate with the planet so it
spins
and he was essentially saying what uh
repeating what i said and he said it
correctly so i hope you understood it
and i hope everybody else understands it
and there's an illustration of that the
moon spins together with its axis and i
put a three-dimensional axis there so
you understand the concept
that's what we're looking at here we're
not interested in uh
belief we don't care if you believe in
this or not it's it's irrelevant right
now we just want you to understand the
concept the concept is the concept is
that if the moon spins what we're saying
is
that the
axis that runs through it uh does not
spin but if it spins like in that case
together with the moon then the moon is
not spinning because this any point on
the surface is not changing its distance
with respect to that three-dimensional
axis on the other hand in the case of
the earth it's as if we had a solid
fixed
standalone you know unmovable
uh axis three-dimensional axis again
and the surface moves and changes
its distance with respect to each point
on that axis okay so that's the concept
that's the definition we're going to go
with okay you don't like it all you got
to do is bring your definition and
hopefully you address
the issues that will be talked about
today okay
okay so here uh if i'll said it
correctly i hope uh you understood more
or less what i'm saying okay
another fella says okay he says uh
it's quite confusing it's quite a
confusing analogy yeah he's he's quite
confused no doubt about it it says is it
not the case that the moon has ice caps
top and bottom
okay
uh that would mean that it spins or not
spins in relation to the sun as well as
the earth
well i'm not sure what the
fact that it's got ice caps has to do
with the sun or the earth you know
uh he hasn't made his point
okay and isn't the moon just tidally
locked with the earth in the first
instance
well uh let's find out what is this uh
tidally locked we have no idea what this
is okay let's find out it says tidal
locking between a pair of co-orbiting
astronomical bodies occurs when one of
the objects reaches a state where there
is no longer any net change in its
rotation rate over the course of a
complete orbit in other words
uh you have a rotating body let's assume
the
at some point the
moon spun around
and over the millions of years slowly it
slowed down until it finally
gave a single face to the earth and it
no longer spun
okay and so now it's tidally locked
because it doesn't spin
yeah that's the issue but the
interesting
part also uh related to that is high
tides and low tides are caused by the
moon
okay
and the moon's gravitational pull
generates something called what the
tidal force
newton discovered or theorized that the
moon
affects the tides on earth okay
and uh so well it goes on and on but
this is the the issue
here's the earth and here's the moon
okay and the question there is uh what
causes the tides if the moon is 380 000
kilometers away
how does the moon
affect the tides how does the earth
compel
the moon to um
have this uh
uh
what is it the you know the fact that
it's tidally
locked
in other words
how does the moon affect the earth
physically and how does the earth affect
the moon physically if you don't put a
something in between there then you're
doing uh your theory with ghosts and
with angels
okay that's what it is you're putting
you're doing black magic
hopefully if uh you're going to talk
about tidally locked or tidally anything
you know the moon affecting the tides on
earth hopefully you can tell us the
mechanism and you can tell us how one
object affects the other
uh through 380 000 kilometers of
distance
okay and so and you can't use concepts
that's even worse you might as well use
uh
ghosts and angels okay
so um
again anyone who uses the these uh
notions of tidally locked and says that
the moon affects the tides on earth and
that kind of thing no problem
i think they do
the question is what is the mechanism
if you can't tell me the mechanism don't
just
say things that you read about or or
copied and pasted from the wikipedia or
whatever and say oh see it says title he
locked here yeah explain why explain the
cause the mechanism
then you can talk about tidally locked
okay otherwise don't mention it okay
don't say that mass did it or energy did
it or a field or a force
you know time
okay and then uh says uh a better
analogy might be the rotor in an
electric motor as it has in a shaft to
rotate about
and i discourage the use of the word
rotate okay because rotate is ambiguous
you can rotate around a planet meaning
you orbit it and you can rotate around
your axis meaning you spun or you're
spinning and so the question is
you know whether we should use the word
rotate which is so ambiguous and i'm
going to encourage everyone to use the
word spin
or orbit because those are very
clear-cut or in the minds of most people
out there orbit is what you do around
something else spin is what you do
around your own axes okay and so
i'm gonna stick to spin and orbit stay
away from the word rotate which which is
what is confusing this fella up here
okay
it's it's uh the confusion comes from
using synonyms which have never been
defined in fact none of these words have
ever been defined scientifically
and that's what we're going to talk
about in a minute here okay it says uh
you go on another fella you go on about
defining axis as being a 2d 3d object
made up of two spatially budding uh
non-coinciding planes which you call
edges when all this has nothing to do
with why you believe
moon actually rotates with its axis
whereas earth does not
uh well the first issue we have to look
at is this word believe
we have nothing to do with belief this
is not about belief this is explaining a
mechanism based on a definition because
we're trying to justify the definition
and what we're doing here is uh you know
just putting a definition and arguing
uh
the fact that spin has to do with a
fixed axis that's what that's how we're
defining it and that's the definition
we're using to explain this phenomenon
known as spin okay and so i'm giving you
something objective
if you don't like it you got to come
back with an objective definition and
argument
not say that
we have a belief there is no such thing
as belief in science okay so this word
belief should uh exit your mouth in your
brain you should come into science
talking about objective explanations
objective mechanism objective causes
that's what this is all about okay
and yeah i'm gonna go in a minute again
uh of why we use this 2d or 3d axis okay
and i'm going to get that in there in a
second okay but here um
here you see uh
essentially why we need that axis there
okay and why we need a
anything other than a one-dimensional
axis but the problem here is this word
rotate which is equal to spin it's also
equal to orbit and also e equal to you
know every other word like spiral and so
on
so rotate is is a word that we do not
want to use
let's use spin and let's use orbit what
expense meant a circular motion of an
object's surface with respect to what
its fixed
axis the axis has to be fixed okay
and uh
in the case of orbit it's the circular
elliptical motion of a body around
another
okay
so these are different so if you look at
the guy in the uh first uh
the guy who's walking around in circles
there
is he spinning
well no he's orbiting he's not spinning
okay
why because he is not spinning with
respect to his own axis okay and so the
question is is his axis standing still
or not
is it moving with them and right now we
have no indication that it is uh
standing still
and we have no indication that is moving
and i'll tell you why in a minute okay
on the other hand the fellow on the
right looks like he's spinning but again
we won't know the guy in the center uh
because we don't know if uh if his axis
is standing still or not
okay
and again that's that's gonna be your
argument whether the axis is standing
still
whether it's moving with whether it's
fixed or rotating together with the
object okay
and people say oh what are you talking
about bill
okay let's find out
uh
here we have one more fella we uh
pointed out um
something related to this and he said
points and lines are axiomatically
defined
by their wet parameterization
here lies the rub okay so when you look
at parameterization
process of finding parametric equations
of a curve a surface or more generally a
manifold or a variety defined by an
implicit equation what is a parameter a
constant or a variable a numerical or
other measurable factor in other words
uh
he's saying that points and lines are
defined by equations numbers variables
no not in science okay maybe maybe in
mathematics
maybe that's how they define things
there which is not a definition at all
so no it's not
defined through parameters or anything
related to equations or numbers or
variables that's exactly the problem you
end up with situations like in quantum
mechanics where they define spin and
they say was minus half spin or one spin
or plus half spin
what do you mean minus half spin what
the hell is that
i thought spin was spin was spin and it
turns out that spin is a number
um you know one of these quantum numbers
and so no we don't define spin with
numbers not if you're later on going to
insinuate that that means that the thing
is
spinning like a top
one thing has nothing to do with the
other the fact that up top spins has
nothing to do
with the notion of spin
for example for an electron when they
talk about electron spin they're not
talking about it's spinning the notion
of spin that we normally have right uh
we're talking about orientation when you
measure at that point in time it's got a
given orientation that's what they say
and the orientation is either up or down
so what what kind of spin is up what
kind of spin is down
what kind of spin is minus half or plus
half
and again this is the problem we do not
use numbers to define spin the other
thing is that you should be aware of is
that spin
is a physical phenomenon it belongs
exclusively to physics in mathematics
there is no such thing as spin
they have no use for the word spin in
mathematics
pure mathematics okay now the
the problem is that the mathematicians
they started
venturing into physics
and so they created this religion known
as mathematical physics
and that's when they put numbers
together with things
concepts together with objects and they
blended them together and created a big
mess
and we've had this big mess at least
since the days of the greeks and it
hasn't stopped till today
so you know you talk about a singularity
like a black hole singularity and you
say okay i know what a singularity is
it's a little dot
no no singularity is a number okay it's
a number that's what a singularity is
it's got to do with equations it's got
nothing to do with a dot for example
okay again that point the word point
means two things it means the location
and it means the dot
both that's what mathematical physics
has done throughout the ages okay they
blended things with concepts
and
that's where they ran into trouble and
that's why uh they got space-time
four-dimensional space-time unimaginable
they don't care
it's four-dimensional space-time and
then you ask them why does the earth fly
out of the solar system well they said
there's a depression in time
we have warped time what the hell is
that okay why because they've turned
time into a physical object they blended
the physics the fishnet together with a
concept called time
they put them together and they said
space time you got it right yeah
that's how it's spun done
okay but it turns out this guy says uh
lines are axiomatically defined
are they you know when i look it up this
is this is what i see okay you correct
me if i'm wrong points in line says
axiomatically defined and here you look
it up it says point lines are undefined
terms everywhere i mean these are from
the google i just googled uh points and
lines and everywhere you see undefined
turn point in line and plane also
so all these are undefined terms
you know admittedly by everyone out
there
okay
so everybody essentially says that
points lines and planes are undefined so
i don't know what this fellow says that
they're axiomatically defined okay
and
but then after
saying that these points lines and
planes are undefined they go ahead and
they
attempt to
define them here it is these are what
you find for point point is a geomet in
geometry is a location
it has no size
no kidding how can it have size if it's
a location there's no such
object called location objects can only
have size and these people are talking
about the size of a location
and then they say a line is extends
infinitely
well then if a line extends infinitely
it's not an object it's not a thing
because there's no object that is
infinite all objects are finite in fact
it's a synonym of the word object to say
that it's finite meaning that a line is
a concept there's no physical standalone
object called line and yet they always
draw a little
uh line right
and a little elongated rectangle to
represent the line
and they say the line is one-dimensional
but yet what they draw is always
two-dimensional so the elongated
rectangle
and wherever you look you see this
location in size location and size okay
all of them talk about location and size
and so
that's what a point is and the line what
is the line well the line really is
one of two things it's either
a row of apples or an apple that's
moving down the street okay an itinerary
of an apple
and both those notions
are the line and the mathematicians use
whichever one they need at any given
point in time depending on the context
okay so we have a problem we have a
problem because we don't know what a
line is and turns out the line is one
dimensional and it's made of zero
dimensional points which makes no sense
whatsoever so what are these people
talking about well it turns out the
point is not even a point it's a in
other words it's not not the dot that
you're staring at it's the location the
dot supposedly represents
and the line is again one of two things
it's either an itinerary
or it's a row of apples
and so
they use these
concepts mixed with objects and they put
these
pictorial representations of these
concepts and people confuse the
uh the pictorial representation with
what it represents the concept it
represents that's where the problem is
and again it's because math and fizz you
know they can never be reconciled
mathematics has nothing at all to do
with physics and that's where the
problem is okay and people have problems
understanding that
that's one of the first things you got
to grasp
okay and another foul says uh i know i'm
sorry
this is a an outline of what i'm saying
that uh mathematical physics has
done over the years you know they
equated concepts with objects that's
what it is and they say that an accent
exists is also equal to an object why
because objects are defined as that
which you can touch
or see
and exist is that which you can touch or
see
and that's why these words are synonyms
and that is not true
not not at all not in science
and uh what is a dot its location they
call it a point
both of them the dot and the location
are called point uh what is a line in
itinerary it's also a row of apples okay
so a line is both
uh
surface they equate it with plain number
they think it's a thing
no a number is not a thing number is a
verb
number is action number is
uh moving your arm up and down and
counting
apples or whatever you're counting
number lines equal to coordinate number
line equal to dimension number line
equal to vector all these are synonyms
according to the mathematicians okay and
that's not true the coordinate dimension
and vector belong to physics exclusively
number lines belong exclusively to
mathematics never the twain shall mean
and then they say that space is 3d
so they take a solid and they say 3d
space yeah sure
no no space doesn't have any dimensions
whatsoever and you should not confuse
the black stuff in the night sky that
dark stuff which they say is filled with
dark matter and dark energy you should
not
mix that with the object you know it's
it's the question of
if if you put your rubber ducky inside
the bathtub it displaces water well the
volume that it occupies
is you can say is the space whereas the
rubber ducky is what is 3d the space is
not 3d okay
because there is no such thing as 3d
space
uh without the object
okay and then we have the things of
mathematical physics they've turned
everything into a thing and these are
all concepts uh the force has turned
into a particle they talk about
particles of different kinds of forces
the four forces of quantum mechanics but
what is a particle it's a function but
then they have wave is a thing energy is
a thing field is a thing time is the
thing singularity information everything
is a thing and they start moving these
so-called things around
and that's where they run into trouble
okay
so uh yeah this is the issue the issue
is that
what mathematics mathematical physics
has done is reify concepts
and and they use them back and forth
when they want to talk about the concept
they talk about the concept and then
they represent it with an object and
move that object around people think
they're moving you know they're they say
we're going to move love now and what
they're moving is a heart okay we're
going to move the point
and the point is the location you don't
move a location hopefully not i mean
maybe after 10 beers okay
okay so uh here's the rationale behind
uh the axis of mathematical physics and
this is where uh you really have to pay
attention now okay
uh why is it irrational well because
they start out with a point it's zero
dimensional okay
why because it's really a location
meaning it's
non-dimensional not zero dimensional
non-dimensional no concept has
dimensions okay so they start off on the
wrong foot
then but then they're going to construct
their line with all these 0d points
they're going to say it's a 1d line
so we have a 1d line constructed of 0d
points
which are not 0d they're locations
meaning they're non-dimensional so far
we have nothing in front of us
but they put a row of apples or they put
a solid line across there you know a
solid elongated
rectangle and they say that's a line
and no that's a two-dimensional
uh thing hopefully made of
two-dimensional dots
right that's what we have objectively in
front of us
and they say well make believe
make believe that it's one dimensional
make believe it's zero dimensional well
i can't make believe because i cannot
imagine zero dimensions okay
uh no object is zero dimensional so when
you talk about zero dimensional object
you're talking about nonsense okay and
that's the problem we've had this all
the way since euclid
and they're still using these notions to
today
that's why you end up with a singularity
which is zero dimensional and you say
okay you got nothing so far and they say
oh yeah but that one moves stars around
on the other side of you know
uh
gazillions of miles away
so-called black hole and you say hold it
this singularity moves
a star far away moves it around itself
how did it do that
and forget about how they did it please
show me a zero dimensional singularity
show me that it's an object to begin
with because if you have a concept how
does a concept move a star that's the
question
okay and here we have again a 1d line
can be a row of apples on an itinerary
of one apple okay and the axis is
alleged to be a line in other words 1d
line
that's how they define the axis since
time immemorial okay
but uh then the question is is the
mathematical axis a row of apples or an
itinerary of an apple which one is the
axis well i can assure you that they're
going to be using the row of apples and
not the
you know the itinerary of an apple
they're not going to for every point
they're not going to say okay
let the point in the center move upwards
and create the axis okay and it's just
an itinerary and now the object that's
going around whether it's spinning or
orbiting uh that's gonna
establish its reference to an itinerary
no they they want you to believe at that
point that the axis is really the row of
apples a solid line okay they're going
to have this solid line but the solid
line keep in mind is one dimensional
made of zero dimensional points
so there you have it that's that's what
it looks like uh the one-dimensional
magic
mathematical axis that's what it looks
like
like nothing so far they have nothing in
front of them
why because they're not going to be
interested
in spin or orbit
they're going to be interested in
distance distance travel actually not
even distance separation they're
interested in distance travel
and and what they care about there is
numbers and units
five meters 10 feet that's what they
that's what they look at they look at uh
distance traveled by the tip of your um
measuring tape
okay so so many meters how many feet so
many yards so many miles that's what
they look at and so that's what they're
gonna be looking at and they're gonna
use as a reference a one-dimensional
line axis okay and that's what they're
going to base their
spin
you know with respect to to that okay
and yeah mathematics is
abstract which is exactly the opposite
of physics which is physical
and what math physics has done it's
irrational because it's trying to merge
the abstract with a physical
that's the issue okay
okay so what's the problem with the
mathematical axis well it's one
dimensional and
give me a second here
okay i'm back to normal
okay so what's the problem with the x's
well here's the the problem with the x's
okay here's the mathematical axis it's
either a row of apples
or the
trip of one apple and both of them are
regarded as lines in mathematical
physics
okay so it doesn't matter if you have a
row of apples or the trajectory of one
apple
mathematical physics consider these two
notions which are irregular syllable
uh they consider them as lines and
that's what they call it and that's
going to be your axis one of these two
and they're going to insinuate the axis
is really the one on the left the one on
the row of apples because you know you
can understand if you have a a stick
there that you can move around the stick
you can't move around an itinerary
because it's like what's what's left
after the apple's gone well there's
nothing there the row of apples you you
can imagine because you got to stick
there but in itinerary you don't have
anything left okay so they're going to
insinuate that the
one-dimensional axis of mathematics is
the one on the left the row of apples
okay
so what's the issue here well
i put the other day a two-dimensional
stick because there is no such thing as
a one-dimensional stick
and the problem there the big problem
there and the reason these people never
discovered this in the last 10 000 years
none of them okay is that we don't know
if a one-dimensional stick
spins
rotates spirals or whatever orbits
can a one-dimensional
inexistent stick do anything
and even assuming you know
god is the only guy who can see the
one-dimensional stick fine so we'll take
it up with heaven okay so god is looking
at this one-dimensional stick
can he tell i mean he's all no known
right
uh omniscient
can he tell whether a one-dimensional
stick
right one dimensional line
is rotating made of zero dimensional
points by the way is it rotating or not
well you can't you can't tell because
it's one-dimensional it's not fat it's
not thick
it has no width
you know so there's nothing to gauge
whether the one-dimensional axis
is spinning itself
that's why the mathematicians never
discovered it
when they take a distance they take the
distance whether the stick is standing
still or
or spinning it doesn't matter to them
because they're going to look at
distance traveled from this
one-dimensional
concept
and again spin is a three-dimensional
notion that belongs to physics okay
we're talking about a phenomenon that
objects uh can do
and these people are saying okay we're
gonna drive a stake one dimensional
stake through the object that's going to
be our axis and we're going to gauge
whether something is spinning with
respect to that axis
well again the the issue of whether the
axis itself is spinning or not makes a
big difference and there you see why
here you have the two-dimensional axis i
painted color-coded each side red and
blue just to make a point and that's
that you have these two edges
and the distance of the ball changes
with respect to those edges depending on
where it is around that circle
okay so it's straightforward
and i do it with a 2d i can do it with a
3d as well like i did last week okay
and so the issue here is that yeah
if if uh
that stick
that uh two-dimensional axis rotates
it's very different than if it doesn't
rotate because the distance from each
point on that stick to the ball
changes you can't do that with a one
dimensional line one dimensional axis
because
it has no width no thickness
no uh no nothing really there's nothing
there and so you can't gauge whether
this whether it's spinning or not the
axis itself and that's why they never
discovered that you know they only look
at distance and whether the 1d stick
you know when the axis spins or not the
distance is the same
whereas with 2d and 3d it's not the same
okay and again spin belongs to the 3d
world not to the world of
of abstract mathematics
okay so this is where we we have a
problem with all this and that's why
they never figured out the um
the definition of spin for them it's
just a question of distance
and not a question of whether the axis
itself spins because they cannot even
remove imagine a uh
an axis that is spinning or even
standing still you cannot imagine an x
at one d axis okay so
it's because
they introduced this notion this concept
called the 1d line made of 0d points by
the way rub that in
whenever i can
it's because they introduced this notion
and then translated that into physics
and they say oh the earth spins why well
because the surface is moving around an
axis
any axis is one d made of zero d points
rubber one more time yeah
so
no there is no such monster as an x as a
1d axis if you're going to talk about
spin you've got to use
2d if you want fine just to make your
point just to make your argument just so
that people understand your argument and
better yet 3d you know you put a
cylinder in there then you say well does
the cylinder stay put or does it also
twirl with the object like in the case
of the moon and so here's the conclusion
to to all that here you can see why the
moon doesn't spin
and you see the moon compared against
the moon left to right at the top
and if the axis moves around together
with the moon with the surface of the
moon then it's not spinning
okay so i don't care if it takes 27 days
to go around the earth and it as people
say it rotates once around it its axis
no it don't
because if i put a stick
in through the moon
a 3d stick if i grab a
stake right through the the moon the
stick is gonna is is gonna move together
with the surface then it's not changing
its distance uh the surface to
the stick at any point in the stick and
so it's not rotating it's not spinning
which is the correct word
in the other
scenario on the upper right there
that's wrong
and that's not what the moon does the
moon does not the surface of the moon
doesn't any point on the surface of the
moon doesn't change
its location
with respect to that fixed axis to any
point on the axis
okay and then you see the moon versus
the earth the earth does spin because
the axis of the earth is fixed and the
surface moves around a fixed
stick
and so the distance of any point on the
surface of the earth changes with
respect to that axis to any point on the
axis and in the case of the moon it
don't
that's how simple it is okay
do you agree i don't care if you do or
not
science never cares whether you agree
and whether you believe okay in science
we try to understand the concept and if
you have a better concept
then you
get in the ring with shield and sword
and defend your concept
that's the way it works okay
very simple
okay and here we have uh another follow
he said um is the temp uh thermometer
thermosphere
5000 degrees or not this is what nasa
claims is the reason why we can't get
past low earth orbit i guess uh
one of these moonies who believes we
never went to the moon because we would
go through the thermosphere and fry
astronaut would you know maybe the
rocket makes it through but not the
astronaut because he would be fried at
5000 degrees
okay
and please explain the physics of this
layer of the atmosphere
okay let's explain that very quickly
very simply okay this is what this fall
missed okay the thermosphere okay it
extends up to about a thousand
kilometers above the earth the
temperature is about 2500 degrees c uh
yeah maybe around 4500
fahrenheit
but there's not enough gas molecules to
transfer the heat to you
imagine if i take a match can can you uh
can you be burned by a merch match i
mean can you put your finger there on
top of that flame and stay there you
know for two hours assuming the match
stay stayed lit uh long enough uh no it
would burn your finger
but see i can throw that match at the uh
at the astronaut and it's not gonna burn
them
and that's the issue there you don't
have enough matter you don't have enough
atoms you don't have enough molecules at
1 000 kilometers above the earth even
though it's hot there there's very few
molecules to really burn you
okay so
an astronaut could just be outside his
capsule
at a thousand kilometers above the earth
and he would not fry because even though
the temperature of each molecule there
could be as high as 2500 degrees uh it's
uh there's not enough uh material there
to burn him okay aside from the fact
that at that point they usually
go inside their rockets okay inside
their capsules
okay so hopefully you understood that
let me get these out of here
and then uh finally another fellow says
uh
i like this one another mooney says we
never went to the moon right why what's
his argument i think that's what he's
proposing i think that's what he's
saying we didn't go to the moon why well
he's saying that uh went through the
other side give me a second here
obs has that thing where
you can overshoot and it goes it takes
your thing out to the other side he said
mount everest is littered with hundreds
of bodies
the moon doesn't have one dead body
so i guess he's looking for proof
if we find a dead body on the moon then
it means we did go to the moon but if we
don't find a dead body then we didn't go
to the moon
you need to look deeper into the moonies
claim
what can i say
uh people look for proof evidence that
we went to the moon
and uh no we don't do proof or evidence
in science first of all okay
and we you can make an assumption say
let us assume we went to the moon and
explain the theory with that
and you can explain many types of
theories with that one could be gravity
and whatever for example you could say
why did the hammer
and the
feather when they dropped it on the moon
why did they fall at the same time and
so
you make the assumption you know let's
assume we went to the moon we threw
these two things and this is what we
observed you know and now you try to
explain gravity you know so you could
use that for anything but uh
this belief that people have or unbelief
uh that we went or didn't go to the moon
it really plays no no
important part in science itself in
physics okay so
do not harp on it uh but
i can tell you that uh i doubt very much
that a program that has lasted at least
since the 1960s that's how that's 60
years now uh you know and thousands of
people working
year after year after year decade after
decade
and that all that is a hoax
uh
this is not like jfk's assassination
this is not
not like 9 11 that happened in one hour
or whatever this is something that's
going on for years you can go to cape
canaveral you can go to houston or
jet propulsion labs you know and you can
go there and find out what they're doing
uh if they let you in
and uh you know they send these rockets
and you can you don't even have to be
inside there you like i said you can
take your telescope
and you can take your camera your
super duper camera
and you know watch how that rocket goes
out
right
and you can film all of it you can see
that it goes out into space
in fact uh the skylab still rolling
around the earth and you know if if you
have a good telescope you can see it
so what is that thing up there
i don't know
maybe angels
okay
here we go uh with uh this dark energy
this evil
dark energy what is this dark energy
that these people talk about well the
other day we talked about dark matter
okay
and we found out that uh
the mathematicians
mathematicians because we're talking
about the mathematical physicists
what these people do is uh they say
uh dark matter is this this and this and
that okay
and then the next sentence they say but
we don't know what dark matter is
did i hear right
dark matter is a particle
it's heavy
it's dark
but we don't know what it is well you
just told me what it is what do you mean
you don't know what it you just told me
and that's the situation okay
so we have this uh situation here
okay
where they say well look it's particles
it's ultra heavy it's dark actually it's
not dark as i showed the other day or
argued the other day right
invisible translucent or transparent but
not dark you can see right through it
and you can see the stars in galaxy is
right through the dark matter halo of
any galaxy
so this dark word is wrong
it's misleading because people say okay
they're bowling like the eight bowling
ball you know or the
i'm sorry the
eight uh
ball in uh billiards or or even the
bowling ball you know the bowling ball
is black
dark right and is that what this dark uh
matter is just a bowling ball
and
the answer is no because if it were
black if it were dark we would not be
able to see through it and right now we
can see through it there before the word
dark is wrong should be
uh transparent translucent invisible
maybe any of those words
and so now they're trying to find this
stuff the astronomers are pointing their
telescopes they're trying to see it in
the night sky around the galaxies maybe
between the galaxies right
and the particle mathematicians the ones
who run the accelerators well they're
smashing protons and who knows what else
to see if they can produce this stuff in
the lab okay so that's the situation
with dark matter and uh we had the other
day uh one fall his name is
victor toth and he talked about this you
know you've uh if you can watch the
previous uh
lecture you'll find that you know what
he had to say essentially about dark
matter and again a lot of these people
are trying to find new um equations for
this and here's dark matter there you
see it okay you see the galaxy
and you see the dark matter around it
that's what they're saying that dark
matter is bunch of particles you got to
think of each one of those particles as
very very heavy okay extremely heavy
because they have to produce the
uh mass the gravitation necessary to
prevent first stars from leaving the
galaxy and second um
it's gotta hold the galaxy together and
and and then it's um
the stars on the outside have to travel
fast faster than the ones on the inside
the only way you're going to do that
according to mathematics is you know by
putting these heavy particles on the
outskirts of the galaxy and of course
they can't see them but they say they're
there they've been proven
and so uh
deal with it
deal with it you don't like it take math
okay and this dark matter is also
between galaxies okay we find it uh
that's the theory okay
more than a theory they say they've
proven it now they're looking for it
okay but they're saying this dark matter
is also between galaxies and why because
they believe that
galaxies especially that are relatively
close together influence one another and
they don't see anything in that region
and so they say well there's got to be
some dark matter some very heavy stuff
to produce what they observe through the
scopes okay so that's
more or less where all these people
stand again dark matter has been proven
beyond a
shadow of a doubt
you don't like it take math
yeah
that's the answer
okay and the problem here is that you
don't find this dark matter between the
moon
and the earth okay so here you have the
the moon and the earth you don't find it
in between uh these two objects because
if we were to find it there in between
the earth and the moon since it weighs
so much right yeah one one little
uh grain of sand of one of these dark
matter bits
uh
weighs tons
and it would affect the uh the gravity
between the earth and the moon or any
object for those of you who believe we
went to the moon right any object that
dares go to the moon it would change the
everything because the gravity would
change so what they're saying is that if
we
sprinkle dark matter between the earth
and the moon both newton and equation
and uh einstein's equation they would
both fail okay so you can't sprinkle it
here it's not there they they're not
looking for it between the earth and the
moon they're looking for this stuff
outside of the galaxy and what they
never justified is why is this dark
matter outside of a galaxy and between
galaxies but not within a galaxy why
isn't it here between the earth and the
moon where we could verify it right
so yeah
one would think that these people uh are
chasing ghosts
you know this this is
what it amounts to
i mean what else do you call it uh the
curtain moves and you say it's it's a
spirit spirit my grandmother
and you say hold it what do you mean the
spirit of your grandmother maybe it was
the heir that moved it but the guy's
convinced that it's the spirit of his
grandmother you know
okay
and this is more or less what dark
matter is yes the spirit of your
grandmother out there moving the
galaxies around
and why can't we see it well you can't
see a spirit see it's a soul
it's a concept
abstraction okay so here we have it this
is dark matter conundrum again for you
to understand what dark matter really is
and that is that
uh
the little yellow thing here at the end
of the red line that's a little star and
you can see that the one above is closer
to the center of the galaxy and the one
on the bottom is farther away and that's
going to be the radius there the r on
the
denominator okay
and so if you raise the
little r if the radius increases
the little v which is the velocity of
the star should come down
the problem is that when they put their
scopes out there in in space in the
galaxies they see the opposite they see
that the stars on the outside are going
faster than the ones on the inside
so the farther the radius the faster it
goes and they say how can that be if the
equation suggests the opposite if you
raise the
distance from the center of the galaxy
to the star if if that increases
velocity should go down
and so the way they fix that they say oh
we got a fix for it see again they're
not doing physics what they do is just
play around with the equations they
created this variable known as dark
matter
and it's mass that's all it is and so
they put it in the equation and say okay
that's the only way we can explain it
we've proven it
the existence of dark matter because
it's the only way we can justify that
equation we have to put dark matter in
the numerator quite a bit of it in fact
all these kilograms that they put in
there right
and yeah you can't see a kilogram so i
guess that's why
dark matter is invisible or translucent
or dark or whatever yeah kilograms it's
very hard to see a kilogram you know you
can see the bag of potatoes but not the
kilograms okay but so they put all these
kilograms in the equation thanks to that
they are able to
mimic with the equation they are able to
describe with equation what they observe
what the astronomers of berserk
and so they said we've proven it because
what else could it be
angels
you know but then they asked everybody
to go out and look for it and they asked
astronomers go look for it and they
asked the particle mathematicians go
look for it okay everybody's looking for
this stuff what's the problem with this
well again if you can see there
the size of those
galaxies and you see the halo around the
galaxies well it turns out we can see
right through them okay that's what
that's what happens you can see right
through
the halo of the galaxy so here's the
halo the way they the way they uh
imagine it
so they say okay there's there's dark
matter there okay well if it were dark
it means it would be opaque and you
would not be able to see you know the
stars in the background but you do you
see it right through the edges of the
galaxy
so again the question is whether you can
talk about uh dark matter or
you know why don't why didn't they call
it what what they should have called it
transparent matter or translucent matter
then it would be great but to say that
it's um
you know dark
just confuses things even further
because everybody thinks that these
folks are looking for little pebbles
maybe the size of bowling balls for all
we know that where
way as much as a whole earth
that's what they're looking for very
heavy stuff
particles you can call a bowling ball of
particle but
at the uh universal level it is a
particle right and they say this all
these parting all these bowling balls
are around the edge of a galaxy
but they're translucent yeah
okay so what's this got to do with dark
energy well
if you create the sin you have to create
the you know
the
absolution you have to absolve the
person okay you have to pardon
this person so you have to create this
this
two-world thing okay this duality
and what they did you know if you have
dark matter which is something that
pulls inwards it's a gravitational
effect that this mass produces
then you have to explain why the
universe is expanding
which is what happened
uh when
1929 you had hubble he kind of proved to
all the mathematicians out there that
the universe was expanding and later on
in what is it 1998 i think it was 1998
1989
they went in there and they said oh we
know what it is it's this dark energy
that's pushing
space time you know it's expanding space
time outwards
so you have on the one hand dark matter
tugging in every all matter trying to
get together one with the with the other
right all the galaxies trying to get
together with each other but then this
dark energy
is so overwhelming it's pushing
everything apart
and it's the
struggle between good and evil
okay
the good you can say is the gravity
trying to pull everything together the
evil is
trying to separate everyone make
everybody an enemy of everybody else
kind of like what's happening in the
ukraine
okay so where do we start well we have
this poor fellow his name is feynman and
he was a nobel prize winner and he said
it is important to realize that in
physics today we have no knowledge of
what energy is
so they're going to be looking for dark
energy but they don't know what it is
and the question is whether this dark
energy thing is uh kind of like the dark
matter like you know what is dark matter
well it's a particle it's heavy it's
dark
but we don't know what it is
okay and what is energy well it's this
dark matter it's uh it's this dark
energy it's uh particles it's heavy
and it's dark
but we don't know what it is
is that the answer gonna be here
and you have some people who question
whether that is the case but here you
have mr toth whom we presented uh last
time around
and he said um the missing matter is
called dark matter but the remaining
stuff with negative pressure
again you know if if you have gravity is
positive pressure in this case right uh
dark energy is the opposite it's
negative pressure it's pressure outwards
in the in the universe right
and you can see dark energy 73 of all
the stuff that fills the universe dark
matter forms 23
and all the visible stuff that you see
out there is only four percent total
four percent that's that's the
calculation
okay so uh he says that the bible says
yet at the same time we have not the
faintest clue as to what these dark
things really are
and again i don't understand because
they've already defined what it is
they're saying it's little balls that
weigh a lot
uh particles right that weigh a lot and
they're dark so we know what it is
it's particles that weigh a lot that are
dark
that's what it is we're done it's like
you know what is a dog well a dog has
two
two ears two eyes a tail you know a body
but i don't know what a dog is
i thought you just described the dog
i don't know what a dog is
okay so
here we have the big bang so this is
where we start the we had the big bang
and everything is pushing outwards from
the moment of the big bang
you can see here here's the original
original explosion okay that's the big
bang
uh frame number two because they never
start frame number one and everything is
pushing outwards and creates this uh
um
this uh with a glass that's uh tilted
uh all the beer came out of it okay so
this is where it starts and what they're
saying is what's pushing all this matter
outwards is dark energy
inwards uh is what uh dark matter tries
to do but dark energy is more powerful
it's just pushing the entire universe
this this universe outwards okay
and when when they do that they run into
this balloon analogy and here it is
okay and
what they do is they have
this thing which is the explosion of
space-time that you just saw
and it starts from nothing from a little
point okay which you'll see here okay
and it just expands and what's expanding
all that is known as dark energy what's
trying to pull all these galaxies
together the yellow dots there
is dark matter but whatever dark energy
is it's winning the battle it's pushing
the whole universe
outwards okay and this is the
what they talk about the question is
what's the white stuff what is it
pushing out against
and that's a question you'll never
have an answer to and in fact they say
it's unscientific
because we cannot imagine what's out
there
but it turns out that's what destroys
their theory because if you cannot tell
me what the white stuff is you don't
even have um
you know a physical interpretation you
cannot tell me what you're talking about
you have to identify the white stuff you
got to tell me what that white stuff is
because if the balloon is expanding
why does a balloon stop there what
continues
that's what you got to answer if you
can't answer that thought i mean you can
say it's thought you know
if you cannot answer that question you
cannot even begin your presentation you
don't have a theory okay a theory is
what an explanation
okay so they don't have an explanation
for for this balloon analogy that
ridiculous really because they think
that the universe is this
sphere
and the galaxies are not really inside
what they are is on the outside just on
the surface of this expanding balloon
okay so all the galaxies are on the
surface of
the balloon like if you you see a
balloon that's polka dotted you know
and you blow the balloon and all the
uh little uh dots become bigger
but they also become separated from each
other because the balloon is stretching
right
and so one of the questions
that has always come up is
why doesn't the dot why don't the
galaxies also get bigger and bigger and
fly apart kind of you know as the
balloon expands
and they say well locally both
gravitation and electromagnetism pull
everything together
and
then galaxies can separate from each
other as the balloon expands
okay and then why does the andromeda
galaxy why is it blue shifted why is it
coming towards us and will apparently
hit the
earth uh around 2.2 million year light
years in the future
2.2 million years in the future because
you know it's i guess traveling at the
speed of light
and so
andromeda is coming towards the milky
way and so is the rest of the local
group it's like they're all coming
slowly together
and you're saying well hold it the
balloon is expanding and all these
galaxies are on the surface should these
galaxies have more distance between them
as time goes by
that's not the case with the local group
the local group is coming together and
the answer to that is well here gravity
is stronger than
dark energy
the dark energy is not powerful enough
to overcome the attraction the
gravitational attraction between
galaxies that's the answer okay so it's
all ad hoc
okay they're trying to explain why when
they look through the scope they see
what they see and then they try to
explain it
usually with equations with mass with
gravity
and
and that's the that's that's the the
science we have today the mathematics
that we have today
okay so uh there are some skeptics of
dark matter dark energy i think
i don't want to put words in his mouth
but i think mr toth whom i talked about
the other day is uh
an atheist or becoming an atheist or at
least an agnostic
in dark matter and dark energy so dark
energy could be just artifact an
artifact of the so-called cosmological
constant you know uh
einstein's cosmological stein uh
constant his biggest error as he said
or the potential energy of a so-called
scalar field
or maybe just energy of the quantum
vacuum i don't vacuum what is the
quantum vacuum all these particles that
come in from the void you know they make
the void
and one comes in
well both of them come in they separate
and they live momentarily it's called
the virtual particle then they go back
forming part of the vacuum and the
question is when they come out do they
leave a hole behind
momentarily is there a hole in space
and what is that hole in space if space
is made out of particles what's the hole
the hole in and what
so this is the issue uh you know they
they they never
were able to figure all these things out
okay they just talk about the particles
coming out and doing this and putting it
back because they need that to explain
what happens in the lab that's their
explanation but then they don't take
that extra step and say well when the
when these two particles came out of
being part of the vacuum what was left
behind a hole a hole in the vacuum
a hole in nothing
that's it's scary stuff really
you wonder how much uh
beer these people drink you know
anyways uh so he says i believe that we
need to find ways uh to you know
actually detect these dark thingies
before we can say anything definite
about their nature perhaps these dark
thingies do not even exist
blasphemy blasphemy because it's already
been proven and this gentleman who is
not officially a physicist
he says he's a part-time physicist
meaning that he's a self-taught
physicist
a mathematician really and
he's suggesting
something that goes counter to the
catechism of the
establishment you know the party line
and that is that they've already proven
that dark matter and dark energy exists
and he's questioning that okay
they are mirages of source because we
are doing what the math using the wrong
theory of gravity
what he's working on is essentially a
modified called mog
mog
it's a modified gravity that's what he's
working at he wants to modify the
equation he's saying out there at that
distance
dark matter and dark energy do not
really exist what we have is simply a
different
a different equation should be used to
mimic or
describe what's happening at you know at
places like the edges of the galaxy or
between galaxies okay so
they're looking at the equations they're
saying there is no real dark matter dark
energy at least that's what they
insinuate okay that's their gut feeling
that there really isn't any dark matter
but they can't go out there and say it
because if they do they're going to be
you know
be ostracized they're going to be kicked
out of the club
and so they have to be careful what they
say and the worst thing they can say to
a fellow like toth is you're not a
physicist anyways
you don't understand
that's uh he
he died they tell him that okay
okay here we have another uh
lady sabine hassenfelder and she says
the little redshift supernovae
were in one direction while the high
redshift ones were in another direction
problem it's a skewed sample she was
talking about you know these uh papers
that analyze the fact that maybe just
maybe
um
dark energy doesn't exist
and again she's in in dark matter
just in case also she she has a little
doubts
i think more than doubts on dark matter
again she's playing around with the
equations okay so all these people are
playing with the equations and they're
not looking through the telescope saying
i'm not going to see this stuff so
why bother what i'm going to do is just
do my calculations and try to mimic with
the equation what i what these people
are observing out there and so it says
the recent paper claims dark energy does
not exist
talk about blasphemy you know
she she could get in trouble for this
you know if dark energy is real the
universe will expand faster and faster
until all eternity okay all this stuff
pushing
all the stars everything outwards right
if there's no dark energy the expansion
will slow down instead and it might even
reverse
in other words dark matter triumphs over
dark energy so to speak okay
in which case the universe will collapse
back to a point
okay so apparently uh this lady
uh she believes that we came out of a
point
and we probably go back to a point known
as the oscillating universe
you know we started out a big bang get
to the big crunch or maybe
not even reach there you know somehow
gravity pulls everything together again
and we go back to the point and it's
this point to expansion
back
point to expansion
back and so on so this is the
oscillating universe i guess she's
thinking about and she's trying to um
you know
describe that with an equation that
process
of why
matter comes back together to be a point
okay and here's the paper she's
referring to the fellow said the best
fit today to rejecting isotherapy
and consistent with no acceleration so
he was saying there is no acceleration
of uh
galaxies outward from each other there
is no uh dark energy essentially pushing
all these galaxies outwards okay does
the cosmic acceleration deduce from
supernovae
may be an artifact of our being
non-copernican observers rather than
evidence for a dominant component of
dark energy in the universe so some
people are starting to question this
came out 2019 by the way so some people
are starting to question you know from
the establishment
uh whether there is such a thing as dark
energy out there
is there something pushing all these
galaxies outwards or was it simply from
the initial big bang explosion whatever
that was you know so we have this
explosion and it's like a hand grenade
you don't really need something pushing
the the uh
the little uh
uh shrapnel you know
on and on and on it's from the initial
explosion that you know you got
everything going outwards so so to speak
you know but you know even when you
throw a hand grenade you know the pieces
don't come back together
but you say well there's not enough
matter to produce this gravitational
pull okay
but that's what these people are looking
at they're saying okay there was this
explosion but now gravity is going to
pull everything back together and so
that's what they're that's what they
work on they work on
uh
the equations they're they're simply
trying to mimic
with their equations again tautology
right they're trying to
make ad hoc equations that match what
they observe out there that's all that
mathematical physics is
do they have a mechanism
i mean what is the mechanism even i'll
concede dark matter let's start there
i'll concede dark matter a bunch of
particles heavy particles whatever
okay so you have all these loose
discrete particles all around the galaxy
what is the mechanism by what mechanism
do they compel stars to go faster and by
what mechanism do they prevent stars
from leaving the the galaxy
i mean if they can't answer that they
don't have physics what they have is
just an equation that says this is the
description
and that's where we stand today okay
okay so here we have uh something we
discussed the other day and uh i was
supposed to put this as the
question and answer um segment but it's
part of this subject so i'm just going
to introduce it here
in what i've been covering right now and
it's got to do with this i showed this
the other day that under the rope model
you have this linear regime which is
between any two stars and on the right
we're going to have the sun and on the
left we're going to have
the centauri system and i'm saying that
any object that tries to leave the solar
system will encounter the bird speak
which is a region that has no gravity
okay i call it the linear regime okay
and so here it is you can see it again
you can see the sun on the right the
alpha centauri on the left okay proxima
centauri whatever
and any
uh
rocket or whatever that tries to leave
the solar system will encounter this
region this linear regime okay that's at
the end of the bird speed
and this this is how this is how you
would be traveling for eons through
these ropes that come into each one of
the atoms of your spaceship and you
yourself okay
why am i putting this up there well i'll
tell you why because fella asked the
question he says the following
because i don't quite get how
the lack of gravity in the linear regime
slows down the spaceship when in fact
there's less
fan out of ropes
[Music]
on it from either side
yeah uh i guess he has problems
visualizing this he's saying look uh
the farther you get away from the sun
the fewer ropes you have right because
the ropes are coming together the
farther you are and he says you know we
should be traveling
uh
uh if anything faster and not slower
right now we have a
the the pioneers that's what this was
all about the pioneers are closer to the
sun than they should have been they
should have been farther out okay and so
he's saying how do you do it with ropes
i don't understand uh looks like that
you know
and the farther you go out there the
ropes come in and they become a single
coaxial
you should be traveling faster rather
than being pulled towards the sun
that's what he's uh questioning here
okay
my understanding of it is that
considering the so-called mass weight of
the spaceship relative to either star
and the distance remains the same the
factor that might be changing is g the
gravitational constant g
the gravitational okay there is the
gravitational constant it might be not
be a constant after all okay
uh you should research that and do your
calculations i did quite a few of those
on the gravitational constant now it's
your turn
okay
is that what bill is saying here when he
states that newtonian gravity is no
longer at play here
okay
and before i answer this gentleman
there's another gentleman who uh put a
known he says so the ropes don't follow
a straight path between objects why not
and i'm assuming i don't want to put
words in his mouth but i'm assuming he's
referring to the bird's beak you can see
there's a curve
there
and so he thinks that
the ropes there are curving
okay
i think that's what he's referring to
he's saying i thought they were all
straight they were all tight
and the answer is yes they are all tight
and so let's answer this gentleman first
okay then move on to the first one
here it is
we can produce these patterns all with
straight lines
and you can see they're curved you say
how can it be curved it's curved but
it's all done with straight lines
okay so all those all these these two
patterns were made with straight lines
and that's essentially what we're saying
that happens in the bird speech we're
doing it all with straight lines in
other words we're doing it all with pot
ropes connecting atom to atom
okay we're going to be producing a curve
okay a curve of the net you can say of
ropes
we're going to produce a curve of the
net through with straight lines okay
and so here let me show you the bird's
beak okay this is the bird's beak and i
did this all with straight lines okay
all this is done with straight lines but
you can see a curvature at the top and
why is this curvature well this
curvature we have to understand why the
cause what
what triggers this
it's that if i ask you how many atoms
are there at the top at the pole of the
sun
versus how many are in its equator in
this picture well you would say there
are more atoms around the belly the
center of the
sun than they are at the very north pole
in fact at the very north pole of the
very south pole there should be a single
atom that's out there
you know and so there should be only a
single rope from that atom to anything
like to the centauri system
on the other hand if you look at all the
atoms are in the
middle of the sun there should be
gazillions of them there and so that's
why you see more ropes running down the
center okay
what's going to become the
linear regime then you have uh at the
top okay so all ropes are connected from
one sun to another like from the our sun
to the centauri system so i put those
ropes there i drew those but the the
reason you get that curvature is that as
you go down this object the sun you
should get more and more ropes as you
get to the center of the sun okay so
that's what produces the bird speed and
the bird's beak as you can see
is not a perfect
uh square of the distance function like
is newton's newtons would be a perfect
triangle in fact i should have uh drawn
that there but newton would be a perfect
triangle this is not a perfect triangle
this is a curved
side triangle okay
it's not a quad it's not an exact
triangle
okay so so that's the situation there
okay so where do we go from here well
here you see the linear regime okay
and i've drawn the bird speak and both
uh our sun which is the one on the guy
on the right i should have labeled that
and the one on the left is the centauri
system alpha centauri or beta whichever
doesn't matter so the issue is you can
see the bird speak there okay
why because again most of the atoms are
in the center of the sun and of the
alpha centauri there
and relatively fewer much fewer are in
the the ones that go straight ahead from
sun to sun okay so you should produce a
bird's beak
under the rope model under the rope
assumption okay
okay so here you have our starship and
it's gonna leave the earth
okay
and so
it travels and when it's close to the
sun it's more or less uh square of the
distance so the rope model pretty much
matches newton
the point at a there okay that's our
rocket there at a and
the rope model essentially mimics or
matches almost perfectly
newton's square of the distance function
no problem but what happens when your
spaceship hits
the point where
more and more the
ropes go straight ahead
from
our sun directly to
to
alpha centauri system what you have is
that linear regime
and there there is no gravity because
that you don't have the square of the
distance gravity in that region
and so what happens when your ship comes
out of the s out of the sun yeah in this
case out of the solar system once it
hits that region let's assume it was
just a
fixed place uh it's actually um
a gradient okay it's a nuanced uh
region you could say
but let's assume that there's a
clear-cut place at that point where you
hit the
linear regime well what's going to
happen it's like if your rocket hit a
brick wall okay and i liken it to a
diver going from water to
molasses
you know
assuming it's that clear cut it's not
but this is just for illustration if you
go from water to molasses you're going
to be slowed down and that's essentially
what's happening you can also look at
the spaceship coming backwards from
alpha centauri to the sun
you might expect
if you use the square of the distance
you might expect the
rocket at sea
okay assuming it's turned around facing
the sun it's going towards the sun you
might expect the rocket at sea saying
okay i should expect according to
newtonian
square of the distance i should expect
being drawn to the sun here
and it turns out you're not drawn to the
sun because it turns out that you know
you got to go further down if you want
to have gravity
you're not yet in the square of the
distance gravity regime
and so this is what's happening here
what's happening is that when you so
what we're doing here is comparing
newton against the rope in other words
how did these people calculate that the
pioneers were not where they were
supposed to well they used newtonian
gravity
that that's how they figured all this
out okay so let's understand the the
issue the issue is that uh
nasa when they figured out that the
pioneers were not
as far out as they should be they use
newton and they use the square of the
distance
equation
but it turns out that the probes were
closer to the sun
and the issue there is again it's like
the
rocket hit a brick wall
so to speak it's nuanced it's very
gradual in fact that's that's what they
measured that it kept
losing
speed as it went along
okay so that's that's what you got to
mimic with the equations what they did
was they went with the equation they
also said oh there was a heat
dissipation there you know and
preferentially in the direction of
travel and that's what slowed it down
that was their argument and i'm saying
no what you have is this probe is moving
into a region that is not quite
newtonian
okay it's that newtonian it's already
changed and
there is no gravity in that linear
region so it's like if it hit a brick
wall it slows down it's starting to slow
down as it tries to move out of the
solar system and again we're comparing
the rope model versus the square of the
distance model okay so that's what we're
doing so don't think of it in terms of
ropes are there more ropes less ropes
but you got to compare is against newton
because that's how they determine that
they're slowing down or decelerating
towards the sun
okay so that's the story um essentially
the the probes uh
pioneer of 10 and 11 they hit this
region
where there is no gravity and so now
instead of thinking in terms of
newtonian gravity you got to think of a
no gravity region or fewer actually it's
less and less and less but we're just
going to talk about the extremes and say
a no gravity region and so now this
thing is drifting
and and you're expecting it to be
farther out because of newtonian uh
calculations and it's not there because
it doesn't encounter gravity or it
counters really less gravity as it goes
you know as it re
leaves the solar system
that's the story
okay anyways uh we have a final issue
i'm gonna address here and foul says he
says you've completely intellectualized
yourself out of the meaning of
christianity
well no it's not true you know i'm i'm
uh the lord's messenger
i came here to educate you know i
but we educate with you know
a baseball batting i i don't use a
baseball bat because it's too big for
the screen so i use my dough roller but
uh yeah
i'm doing the lord's work here on earth
okay
but if you expected me to
because of that to
you know kiss and make up with all these
people no no we educate with a baseball
bat here
okay with that i'll see you next time
what is it sunday we'll see you on
sunday bye bye